today is a very special day because we
are starting to go to hate reott mail
that relates to the presumption that
Donald Trump will be reelected in 2020
now I don't totally disagree that that
is not only a plausible but a moderately
likely scenario but before we get to
that a quick reminder what is hatred
mail because Mexico is still paying for
the wall right I mean that's what he
said it all the campaign Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay so this is it once again
hatred mail that is starting to deal
with the particulars of what hatreds
believe is going to happen in November
of 2020 let's take a look at this week's
Hadrian male you brakes you should know
better do you I am sick to death of the
self-righteous arrogant [ __ ] like you
rot in hell megawhatts forever and
winning even longer will you cry in
November twenty twenties God duel I hope
to hell you life streams so we can all
see it for myself yeah so listen I'm
going to be doing plenty of life
streaming I don't know that I will be
crying and again as I've said before
that this is a conversation that many
progressive shows have had we all know
that Donald Trump being reelected would
be far better for our programs and our
businesses then I don't know it's
certainly better than just Joe Biden
becomes President of the United States
but I've not seen any progressive host
say and therefore I want Trump to be
reelected I recognize Trump is good for
business and I want him about as soon as
possible but you you may not be wrong it
is certainly feasible that Donald Trump
will be re-elected to another four years
I did a commentary about that on the
Monday show fight hate reott ISM by
signing up for a membership at join
pakman.com using the coupon code hey
tree at 40
saves you 40% and it makes hay tree its
cry that their hate reott ism is not
accomplishing anything for their
political ideology